merci la parole et à monsieur alain
chrétien merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre des finances monsieur le
ministre lors de son audience de rentrée
le 19 janvier dernier le premier
président de la cour des comptes didier
migaud a parlé d'un magicien
oui d'un magicien un magicien venu je
cite animé la fête de noël des enfants
du personnel de la cour un magicien je
cite toujours avec ses tours de passe
passe ses artifices de tous ordres et
ses écrans de fumée qui ont paraît-il
beaucoup plu aux enfants
je ferme les guillemets mais qui est
donc ce magicien monsieur le ministre
est celui qui fait croire que les
déficits ont disparu alors qu avec
l'espagne le portugal et la grèce
la france est encore placé en procédure
de déficit excessif est celui qui
distribue à tour de bras des cadeaux
électoraux qui font exploser la masse
salariale de l'état dont l'augmentation
en 2017 est équivalente à la l'évolution
intervenue entre 2011 et 2016
rien que ça est ce celui qui augmente le
cic e de 6 à 7% de la masse salariale
des entreprises en 2017 avec un effet
bizarrement repoussé à 2018 alors
monsieur le magicien pardon monsieur le
ministre
combien de milliards d'euros de dépenses
non financées supplémentaires allez-vous
laisser à vos successeurs
la parole est à monsieur christian
eckert secrétaire d'état chargé du
budget et des comptes publics
oui merci monsieur le président de la
journée député monsieur le député alain
chrétien
la cour des comptes comme vous être dans
leur rôle
et quand des acteurs jouent leur rôle à
de nombreuses reprises dans la durée ils
doivent toujours veillé à ne pas sûr
joué monsieur le député il est important
pour s'y retrouver de savoir d'où on
vient où on est et où on va d'où vient
ton en 2008
monsieur le député le déficit de notre
pays atteignait
euros il était de 5,1 pour cent du pib
c'est à dire un chiffre inégalé dans
l'histoire de notre pays 2011
c'était là d'où on vient où en est-on en
2016 monsieur le député la cour des
comptes qui certifie régulièrement les
comptes de l'état les comptes de la
sécurité sociale en 2016 le déficit de
l'etat sera de 3 3% personne ne le
conteste c'est à dire qu'il aura été
réduit de moitié et où va-t-on monsieur
le député on va vers un déficit que même
la commission dans sa décision du 16
novembre dernier a reconnu qu'il serait
sous les 3 % en 2017
alors je tiens à vous rassurer monsieur
le député en tout cas cette majorité a
réduit de moitié les déficits publics
al inscrit parfaitement euros après
l'euro l'ensemble des dépenses de 2010
est lié en particulier à la majoration
d'un certain nombre de budgets pour
assurer nos priorités pour assurer la
sécurité des français et ça personne ne
le contestait et mon inquiétude siens
qui est une il ya il y à des
déclarations d'un certain nombre de
candidats à la présidence de la
république particulièrement de ce côté
qui prédisent de ne pas respecter la
trajectoire des finances publiques
ce n'est pas le point de vue de ce
gouvernement merci là bas